claims and katie.davis right or about
but if you if you want to know about it
ask them small reasons what maybe you'll
be mentioned in its talk but I don't
know yeah so what we so we saw what a
lady is just to recap you know the best
fits of space to the data right that's
good in the sense of minimizing some of
squid perpendicular distance so we'll
see how actually two applications but
for similar things because I don't want
to have defined several areas one is
this results about learning Gaussian
mixtures so suppose you had a mixture of
K which is constant K small we assume
vertical gaussians in our D all with
rest and divisions one in all directions
and means separated by a constant amount
so maybe I'll draw a little picture so
it's like this here there are two
gaussians means separated by a constant
right and the variance of the one in
each direction but there could be many
but each pairwise Center is separated by
at least a constant so it really is fits
that mnemonic means separated by a
constant number of standard deviations
right and you would like to learn them
that is you're given samples from a
mixture
I guess well if you know what a mixture
is I should say perhaps so Misha has
just waited some convex combination of
probability densities right
so p1 p2 etc or gaussians and you have K
of them and it's a convex combination
and I generate samples from this you
could also think of it as if I'm picking
one of the peas with probabilities
proportional to the weights and
generating sample from that P or you can
think of it as generating each sample
from the mixture of course I don't tell
you which pit came from your job used to
learn it so you used to find the
Gaussian right well in this case I told
you the center divisions one so finding
just means the means so generally it
could be general non-spherical gaussians
and you you are to find the variance
covariance matrix as well as the mean so
find the gaussians vampire and one give
a polynomial time out when using a
sweetie which I'd like to describe so it
can be done in polynomial time this task
now what I would like to say is first
try distance based clustering
what does distance based clustering mean
just take the example of two I have
samples from both of them I pick up one
of the points and take everybody closest
to it and the hope is everybody in its
own cluster will be closest to it in its
own Gaussian and everybody in the other
Gaussian will be farther from everybody
in the same Gaussian but in this picture
says that's not true I mean don't
believe the picture but it's not true
unless the separation is really large I
won't sit and prove that but it's a
simple calculation so unless you have
this larger separation D is we are
thinking of asymptotic so the Delta
constant it's not true that points
closest to your own points so that's no
good it doesn't help now random
projection does not help random
projection does shrink this as well as
this but not well enough at all to in
fact it gets worse this inequality with
random projections but here is a thought
if only we could project to the space
spanned by the means so in this picture
of two if only somebody would tell me
this subspace spanned by the origin and
this if somebody did tell me that we saw
that I could project to this I get two
nice gaussians now in one dimension
means separated by constant levels and
deviations we all know how to handle
that then maybe we can do this so what
happens then then Delta remains the same
right because we have we are projecting
to the spatial centers G however has
become much smaller namely K and
therefore this inequality is more likely
to be true so then you can do a distance
based in the projection the projection
is very simple
and what when palembang showed and once
I I'll show you this I'm going to show
you this proof in a picture next slide
showed is that in fact the K dimensional
subspace is exactly equal to the
subspace of means if I had the whole
densities I don't have a whole density
that only the empirical I only samples
from the densities then it'll be
approximately I'm going to prove this to
you because it's a very nice proof so
the SVD subspace one dimensional best
fit line is exactly this there's a
confusion in K and K minus 1 but that
ignore that so here's a proof that
there's 3d subspaces of space of me
so take one Gaussian and let let me let
the mean of it not be the origin okay
let's assume it's not the origin I want
to claim the best fit one dimensional
subspace to a single spherical Gaussian
is the line through the center to its
mean so it's centered on the origin okay
so why is that so I'm going to give you
a hand really proof it's easy to write
down and prove it so here's a line that
line splits the sphere into two so these
distances are symmetric about this now
if I wiggle this wine away so it doesn't
pass through the center if it goes like
this for instance some points will get
very close to it but the points that get
very far you have to pay a lot because
it's squaring you have to do a
calculation the calculation is pretty
simple therefore very simple to prove
that this is true but that's the less
intuition that implies also simply if I
look at any K dimensions of space
containing the line it is a best fit a
best fit because they're all oh that's
that K dimensional subspace for the
single girl seam guide implies three
very simply again why so I want to say
now the best fit K dimensional subspace
for for data drawn from K gaussians is a
subspace containing the Centers well
this subspace K dimensional subspace
containing the Centers is individually
the best fit for each Gaussian so of
course it must be the best fit for the
hole right the stronger condition then
being the best fit for the mixture it's
individually a vestige for each one so
this is pathetically Gaussian there are
extensions to non spherical but it's
more difficult so this is really the
proof that SVD subspace hops so here's
an example where random projections will
not do the job but if you did SVD you
get it
now I want to present another example of
the use of SVD to something slightly
more complicated means that is k-means
clustering but similar well without a
stochastic model and I'll say a little
more about that i titled it this way
because i'm going to talk in the next
slide about some more examples there you
can do away with stochastic models of
data and still get results so here the
Terran hypothesis is there's an unknown
k clustering of data it's not chaos
ian's anymore k clustering of data with
cluster centers so and so so that the
following is true and I will explain
that with a picture in a minute for each
I and J two clusters a data point in
cluster I I want to say is closer to its
own center than the cluster Jade Center
so in fact in this sense in plus or I've
been projected to the line joining the
Centers of the two clusters is closer to
mu I and mu J and I'm going to measure
distances by standard deviation Sigma
except I have to tell you what standard
deviation means without stochastic
assumptions I'll tell you that at the
end at the moment just think of it a
standard deviation so what is this
statement saying
so here's the cluster point here's a
data point and it belongs to cluster I
this cluster I and cluster I've Center
is here there's some other cluster whose
Center is here in this picture it's nice
it's closer to this than that but what
I'm really requiring is that I projected
to this line this is distance a this is
B B is greater than a plus some Sigma's
it's not important what the exact
condition is all I want to tell you is
that that's actually a weaker condition
than looking at it in the whole state
there's a weaker condition looking at
these two distances I won't prove that
but this is a primal si that's B prime
this is weaker than B Prime
much we could think but ignore that so
I'm told there is a clustering in which
each data point is closer to its own
center than other centers I want to find
it
the conclusion is in fact you can find
this but this particular cutscene
exactly this no errors in polynomial
time this is a result of myself so I
hope this theorem is clear here we don't
have a stochastic assumption we only
have this deterministic example and
there are two parts to a theorem
both the well the first part crucially
uses SVD part one project the to the K
dimensional subspace cluster there you
can't do exact listening perhaps but you
can do to approximate K clustering in
the projection and the assertion is the
cluster centers are close to the true
centers close measured in standard
deviations stepping back one level I
didn't put up a lot of slides on
clustering but clustering is a big topic
in data science right and k-means is
well k-means is a criterion but it's a
misnomer it's called a algorithm Lloyd's
algorithm I won't revisit that you many
of you know what it is is widely used
the difficulty with Lloyd's algorithm is
if you start badly you can go or a you
completely get the wrong clustering or
not get the correct not get anywhere
near the correct clustering right the
start is crucial what attempts have been
made to find a good starting set of K
centers to run your algorithm and
k-means plus plus is a famous one there
are other ones but I know of no
algorithm which finds cluster centers
which lie within Sigma of the true ones
kemi's process doesn't do that
the difficulty is most of the time you
take data points as clusters in this so
you might take this as a cluster center
but as in this example in general data
points can be very far from the center
so there's nowhere near the center so if
you cluster with this as a center you
get you can get complete garbage and in
fact you do so
the difficulty is finding centers close
to court and court rule centers and SVD
is only way I know how to do that that
part of the proof is easier actually the
convergence now the second part says
once you have these you run Lloyd's
algorithm you converge to the true Plus
range that's hot but it's a nice open
problem to figure out some heuristic or
simple algorithm
perhaps cheaper than SVD which find
centers within few standard deviations
of the correct centers cost remember
under what hypothesis do you want that
perhaps this hike what does prints case
let's assume all of this
I think if you had mixture of
assumptions then it's easy to guess your
assumptions okay but I have to tell you
what Sigma is without a stochastic model
and this is a more general interest but
this sickness is actually define exactly
the same way as if you had a stochastic
model so I take Sigma squared to be
maximum over all directions I take the
data point minus this cluster Center
this vector dot product with the squared
distance and average them it's a mean
squared distance to your cluster Center
it's like a cosmic Morley would have
mean squared deviations and I mean you
could still talk about the mean squared
deviation from the mean and I should say
that I said this I said this that this
is a weaker condition we are assuming
it's weak enough that it it basically
subsumes a lot of our most of the
stochastic model results although with
the catch that in for stochastic models
people have worked out the best
constants best separation and so on but
qualitatively subsumes those results now
this is not of course the only example
there are many examples of doing away
with stochastic models I won't describe
them in detail but just to say that it's
often nice not sarcastic mortal people
can object because it's assuming a lot
so can you do without it well there are
things you can do without it compressed
sensing is an example where the
assumption of incoherence now that's
arguable whether that's too strong also
people argue about that but under those
assumptions they're deterministic
assumptions or restricted isometry
property there's some work on topic
models now where you don't have to
assume the stochastic model now for max
cut and other optimization problems
people have developed what are called
stability assumptions these assumptions
say that my problem is so unique that
any perturbation still leaves a result
unchanged that's what stability means so
but the assumptions may be stronger than
you may want to make in practice but
under those assumptions people can get
algorithms to do these problems another
set another assumption that you often
use is a spectrum of a random matrix how
the eigenvalues are plotted for random
matrix sometimes you can get results
without assuming randomness but assuming
the spectrum has this this is not
something I'm going to touch in depth
now I come to numerical algorithms or
randomized algorithms actually but we'll
come to that with this with a slight
sort of motivating intro or just on this
slide so I in 1990 if you caught I mean
maybe most of you couldn't have been
caught an asterisk right now but I was
so in 1990 if you're asked this question
of a theoretical computer scientist
which of these four methods would scale
up and get applied to large problems
here are the four candidates SVD and
singular value decomposition of the
numerical algorithms now of course this
audience is all heard of it but I must
say in 1990 I may not have heard of it I
mean this was not a standard staple
thing to be offered in TCS theoretical
computer science network flows shortest
paths under the graph algorithms those I
had studied yeah sophisticated data
structures please play trees and you
know things like optimization I'm just
put up for not necessarily exhaust for
this but comprehensive topics I mean not
comprehensive topics with just examples
with high probability the answer would
have been two or two and three not for
this audience maybe but with high
probability among these years people
like I'm going to venture out and say
like but now we know perhaps that the
answer is more one and four so in 1990
if you told somebody that the sort of
most successful web search thing is
going to find the spectrum or
eigenvectors of a twenty billion by 20
billion matrix they were laughed at you
because people didn't want to find
eigenvalues and eigenvectors reason 10
but
matrices math in certain segments of the
search community I mean not all yeah
okay object okay I thought you would
object out hoping no make it 50 I won't
be around so I can tell you well so I
think a combination of all I think the
point is that there was a period when
TCS perhaps emphasized discrete stuff
and did not as much emphasize continuous
stuff and perhaps the point about
machine learning giving us this little
push from from the side is to say look
continuous stuff is very useful
optimization and so on so you gotta pay
attention to board so maybe maybe all of
the above there's a diplomatic answer to
and diplomatic question but yes any
other thoughts okay so why is that of
course you know why I can vectors they
use from PageRank it's so that's one
thing but by the way one nice thing to
tell students is that the people who
develop PageRank and so on based on
eigenvalues didn't say I need to do some
search very fast let me go look at
various books and see what's the method
used no they knew eigenvalues and
eigenvectors right from the start so you
have to know them too to get these
answers right this is something else
okay so the crucial help of course is
decades and century of development and
continuous mathematics and probability
especially numerical origins but I would
like to add to this toolkit randomized
algorithms which I will now talk about
not only this top but there will be
several talks ten clocks and David
wardrobe Mike Mahoney among others will
talk about randomized algorithms so I'm
very introduced at but also we have the
first workshop in September on
randomized
are rules for matrices all of this for
me
so this is a early intro and the other
talks will certainly cover much more
current state of the art research so
while I know my father than modern
matrices can be massive and cubed is too
expensive but not only time space is a
big hassle right random access memory
cannot store matrix cannot so the matrix
so it cannot be accessed quickly they're
streaming models but here I propose
something sent something a little more
intermediate between streaming and write
a simple form a randomized algorithm
you're going to compute on a sample of
rows and columns
we need however so I'm going to sample
some Scrolls and computer only with them
but I can't just say that I want to
prove theorems that say converge or
errors error is such and such also the
sampling should be doable without a lot
of work okay we can do all kinds of
important sampling where we compute a
lot before sampling but that we want to
avoid that if possible input data matrix
may be distributed on service this I
won't say much about other talks might
potentially two scenarios on one method
this is something I want to stress so
the scenario that theoretical computer
science is familiar with this there is
an input to the algorithm and the input
is fixed and then you can do with things
with it that's a view that says the
entire matrix exists somewhere like for
instance the web's interconnection the
algorithm draws the sample perhaps an
interesting alternative input would be
where only a sample of entries are known
or I can press a button and somebody
will give you a sample but will cost you
so recommendation system so a very good
example we're getting people's choices
of what they buy costs money to surveys
right so the nice thing about randomized
algorithms there you pick only a random
subset and work either scenario can
adopt the same method except in scenario
two you better you better have an idea
of the sampling probabilities but they
used to pick the entries right otherwise
you're not going to prove anything but
here we think of one generally that's
here we forget to we think of the matrix
as being present somewhere and we're
going to sample if you want to choose
the sampling probabilities and and
sample so this is a setting n by n
matrix MN and lodge I'm going to do
certain number of iid trials s iid
trials s for sample each I it picks a
random column of a and is allowed to
scale it scale about the coin and
thereafter you have to compute only with
a sampled and scaled columns there are
som so it's enhanced by n matrix and
bias matrix so we are dying to be
sampled and got that we throws it away
and it's clear that for most problems
uniform sampling won't do you know you
could have a matrix with one nonzero
column uniform something will never see
it only see zeros oh you want to see
that so the problems we now some of the
problems we now know that we can tackle
with this is of course first matrix
multiplication simple as it is the
simplest of those problems is just
computing matrix times its transpose
this was actually the original
motivation for all of these problems
this seems trivial but imagine this for
instance you can couch
finding the variance covariance matrix
of a probability density given the
samples in these terms but they're the
matrix is actually infinite right so the
entire distribution all right more
generally you can multiply two arbitrary
matrices we we saw what singular value
decomposition is in low-rank
approximation we can do those with these
sampling things matrix sketches which
we'll see today but we'll see in other
tops as well which are just compact
representations of matrices we'll see we
can do that with sampling I won't tell
you today but this graph falsification
is based on sampling which is based on
some of these things but what are the
nice ideas linear regression which we'll
see not in this talk but now the talks
tensors we won't see but spectral ANOVA
tensor is something similar spectral
norm of a matrix
what are the unit vectors you hit it
with so that you get the maximum it
sampling can be applied to solve this
problem approximately I won't tell you
that today two things no free lunch
samples can not get the correct exact
answer of course we know that there are
errors to be made but we want to prove
error bounds for all infirmities so what
I'm going to save something from now on
it's not just for most matrices that's
not interesting it's for all meters late
worst case notation not much notation
for Venus mom is the sum of squares
spectral norm is what you know it is
that the maximum overall unit length
vectors of the expansion oh well since
they took anything victors the length of
that a is n by n so these are all the
pieces of notation I'll use go on S is a
number of sample code
okay so the first result again these are
early ones and you will see state of the
art in the coming lectures in the next
few days
as well as in the workshop low-rank
approximation with additive error that
we seek here a rank K approximation a
star to a so that either an expectation
or with high probability the following
is true a star wants to be an
approximation to a right and the error
is now first is measured in Frobenius
norm we want that to be best possible
error we can make the lowest error we
can make with any rank a matrix plus a
sampling error and the sampling error
depends on the Frobenius form
so this is one thing we seek and we can
seek the same thing for spectral mom as
well and the main theorem this early
Karen is that the number of samples you
need to prove this is independent of
Internet and indeed you can use this on
infinite matrices as well
why did certain things or convert
certain things to on block so if you
take a polynomial in K the rank needed
and epsilon the error needed
that's the vises provided it doesn't
suffice if your sample uniformly of
course we saw we don't know that it
suffice as father distributions it
suffices when you sample with
probability is proportional to the
squared length of the columns it is
known for some other distributions and
you'll see them later so I'll leave that
for the later talk so what is this this
is saying pick a column with probability
proportional sum of squares of its
entries this is a distribution for which
we know that this theorem works yes
then you do that something when the data
is spread out over processing yes there
is some recent work I won't be talking
about it you can avoid you can
communicate little o of the entire thing
right it's not interesting to
communicate the whole thing too but you
can I don't know whether David might
mention it probably not right yeah it's
somewhat of David's and mine and Santosh
won't talk about it
any other question
yeah well okay there are there will be
other talks which gives you
multiplicative errors sorry
in this setting it is necessary I
believe yeah that is at least SS who
depend polynomial 1 over epsilon now I
say I'm hedging a little bit because I
haven't paid much attention to lower
bound so late but I believe it's
necessary any any other somebody else
might answer that right Lucy I don't
want to support I don't pick somebody
okay so if you do squared length
sampling this is true did this proof
requires a bit of sweat right so I won't
go to proof now this will not be maybe
that sort of the question
this wouldn't be interesting if this is
large right if the right the error is
too large so for instance if the error
is larger than the best possible SVD
error I won't be interested it can be
this can be larger than that for
arbitrary matrices but this the fact
that is smaller holes for matrices
arising in principal component analysis
these are matrices where the top few
singular vectors occupy a fair bit of
the spectrum so which is true for things
that you do PCA lit when you do a piece
here you do it with matrices where the
top few ranks tell you a good bit of
information and then that is true then
in fact this is Plus away
this was in a paper in 1998 again a lot
more has been a lot of lot of things
have been done on the subjects and so
we'll see them okay so
so data handling you could have the
streaming model because the meters are
too large instead most of these results
are done in the following model the data
is too massive to have stored in RAM
that still we assume the simplified
model we measure three resources ran
time and space a number of passes so a
pass we assume is the only way to access
matrix from external memory and you have
to do sequentially read the whole thing
it's of course a simplification but
under these assumptions so most of these
algorithms do only two passes
I said constant but two passes and the
RAM space they use is only to store
order storage this area columns are a
small number of columns or rows the one
passes can be used to find the squared
length of probabilities right we have to
take the square length of each column to
be able to sample important sampling so
we find those and pass to draw the
garbage
okay good smile say are not allowed ask
questions
so sketch of a matrix ah here I'm going
to tell you how a sample of rows and
columns give you information about the
whole matrix right that's what it's
catching
so can a sample of rows form a sketch of
the matrix no because the sample example
the rules tells you nothing about
downsample rules that's not good enough
how about a sample of rows and columns
we'll see the answer is yes so I give
you a small sample of rows small sample
of rows of columns
that's enough that contains information
about all the entries of the matrix with
errors right so first suppose a has some
intuition first suppose a is rank K and
I pick 100 K rows in things are in
decent general position that should pin
down the row space of a right I think
enough rows that I should be getting
more or less so entire rows basically
what I still don't know for each
unsampled row what linear combination it
is of the sample rules right it's
probably a linear combination and with
k's enough to sentence span the whole
space but we don't know what combination
now suppose I pick hundred K columns and
now intuitively is the rows are in
general position there should be a
unique linear way of expressing each row
in the sample in terms of the other rule
spaces right so this is Vinh to t'v so
once I give you rows and columns you
should be able to pin down what happened
that I mean I'll say the theorem
probably next time length squared
sampling of rows and columns we need to
do sampling by length squid
probabilities otherwise C is a matrix
formed by sampling and scaling s columns
of a according to length squid or is a
sample of rows now but a different
number root S that for a technical
reason which but the sampling is done
also according to length squared
sampling and now the theorem is this
if you give me CNR and put a picture
okay this is due to petrol Sultan I
asked me and why there have been a lot
of improvements and there's a very nice
results of both CDs and Woodruff which
gives the optimal algorithm finding this
for finding that you from CLR now here's
a picture so I have the matrix the
assertion of the theorem is I give you a
sample of columns I put that is my C I
give you a sample of rows that's my R
and I put the right size matrix to put
in between which is found just from C n
R and the accession is a is
approximately C times u times off the
dimensions are correct and I can
multiply no ranked assumption
my ring like we want you to be okay if
you want to have but you're not making
assuming that a a small right to start
with though you know maybe it doesn't
necessarily a small but if you want the
rank your there compared to the best
Frankie you can even do boss for this
yeah or spectral um I don't need a
kitten so okay so I mean I guess it's
clear what is right the expected
spectral norm error is this the
expectation is over random choices of
see you know so you should ask do I have
any do you have an intuition for SS the
square root it yes I don't I think now
we know better right do we know without
SN root as both being the same no maybe
not
okay let me let me try to answer your
question right
no I mean maybe let me plant it I yeah
yeah I think it's too involved for me to
formally
yeah so what so now if you do this then
initially let's say that in many
applications one way a matrix is used is
to multiply it by vectors matrix vector
products so if you want to multiply a by
vector X it's much easier to multiply
this because you can see that the
multiplication time is smaller I can
multiply R times X and new times that
vector and C times this is that one use
of it there are the users that that are
made of this in database I won't go to
the application may be is there any
other question so there are a number of
other results again you will see more
there is a statement in the Frobenius
norm to which I didn't make to see the
reason I made that spectral norm is that
I can put an absolute bound here because
by the time I go to s the spectral norm
would have fallen I mean the singular
value has so fallen the Slovenians
normal knot but there is a result of
even if there are different servers or
something measures of the rows right so
the distributed computing has to be done
without assuming entire columns are in
one server so they increase or split
pell-mell and you have our algorithm
which I won't talk about do develop a
way of communicating so that you can get
a sample but yes if it's column wise
split rows sampling is difficult
other distribution okay
good point I should mention that you
don't have to sample exactly from length
quick it's enough to be the probability
of a column needs to be at least let's
say a constant times the squared length
that is sufficient now if I can only
sample from some uniform distribution
you can get a result but the variance is
high so for any distribution you can get
a expected bound but it won't be very
good necessarily there'll be other
distributions based on leverage scores
and so on which would be talked about in
the other cluster more confident
something but give you better
yeah if you just take the rose with the
largest nor along with the largest
Norman if they're counterexample they
can yeah so if you had one column with
epsilon greater norm than zillion of the
columns you get the wrong answer right
you've missed it
so actually yeah but if you would use
that expression to do the regular vice
inverse so in this is a bit of a problem
because the area is here or proportional
to not have it in the other one
proportion to the Frobenius norm the
lowest singular values which determine
inverse more or likely to be likely to
have too much hair for you to do
anything so inverse is a problem the
lowest single values are a problem
they're always a problem but also here
regular right okay
what you mean like pre-conditioner oh
that is the field may have a full rank
you're saying inverse in the space on
which the operator did the column space
is that what you're saying
you know what they did not pay a dagger
is that what you're on yes okay so a
dagger I mean that's that same problem
you have to know the lowest nonzero
singular value reasonably well and you
want to know that okay I should qualify
it okay I should qualify all of that a
little bit in the grass falsification
application the the use some results
later results than these for length
squared sampling by Rudolph's and so I
will not talk about that but length
squared sampling the bounds I gave you
here have been improved by functional
analyst and using those so so if you had
a long skinny matrix you can make do
with number of samples that depend on
the smaller dimension and still get the
Penrose inverse correct but you need
number of samples that depends on one of
the dimensions at least
No
okay we can
so I want to visit very briefly another
topic
Markov chains I mean partly because it's
the next chapter in the book but partly
it's not an unnatural thing it's doing
algebra base right you say all over the
Markov chain is based on a directed
graph with positive edge weights the sum
of edge weights going out of each vertex
is 1 at each step to walk is that a
vertex picks on out edge according to
the probabilities walks to the other end
and you'll say the Markov chain is
connected if the graph is strongly
connected because these are directed
edges the fundamental theorem of Markov
chains if you if you have seen the
fundamental theorem you would not
necessarily recognize this but this is
this is my fundamental Markov chain for
a connected markov chain the expected
fraction of the time walk spends at each
vertex converges to a limit and we call
that the stationary probability vertex
it's a function the limiting probability
is a function only of the vertex not of
the starting distribution right now the
usual statement you might have seen says
that the T step probability the
distribution at time T converges is a
much harder theorem and what it needs
also a technical condition called
periodicity of a Markov chain which is I
think a red herring
please don't ever pay attention to
periodicity is not important and I'll
tell you why but it is important to
prove that limit exists right if you
want that mathematical theorem is
important so in in the application in
many applications so you run a Markov
chain if I know that the distribution
instantaneous distribution at time T is
good I stock the Markov chain at a large
enough time and take the sample and that
is that's not what you do you would
using infobar only where it is
instantaneously
is wasteful you would rather take the
running average of all the states you've
been in for the entire run and use that
and that for that this fundamental
theorem is what is needed not the other
one
so if so periodicity goes away if you
average over all so the proof is easier
and maybe I'll try to indicate a proof
but before that now Markov chains are
run usually well in quite a few
instances the Markov chain is too large
is exponentially large but you run it
for a polynomial number of steps and
prove that is almost equally likely to
have in every state so even though the
space is exponential you can prove it in
polynomial time
and you're likely to see each part about
the same fraction of time you obviously
will visit very few states compared to
the total number of states but if you
take any large chunks you're likely to
visit it about the right number of times
already in polynomial number of steps so
such Markov chains are the ones that are
used in practice in statistical
mechanics is one place where regionally
they were used for voting but they are
also used in computer science now for
instance to find the number of metrics
to solve counting propositions but
underlying that is the slide showing
rapid mixing rapid mixing says that the
Markov chain converges a number of steps
much less than the number of states
right number States exponentially
converges in polynomials
so how does one prove that so I'm going
to do it only for symmetric chain
symmetric chain means the probability of
a 1 X 2 y is the same as Y twice but the
tail votes more generally we define
something called the conductance I here
you have a subset of states s and this
is complementary set escape this bar I
want to look at all they just going from
a stress ball the numerator measures the
probabilities added up over all these
and the denominator measures the smaller
of the two sites now the intuition is I
better have a large probability of
stepping out from any set if I want to
be uniformly everywhere right so I need
these things to be large if these things
were small particularly the Markov chain
look like this yes and no way to go to
the state then it may take to take me
infinitely long before an equally likely
to be anywhere and never reach yet right
so this is the condition this being I is
a necessary condition for me to for me
to be equally likely to be anywhere so
and the conductance Phi of the chain is
the minimum overall substance so if you
had a Markov chain and I should have
drawn these pictures get a Markov chain
that look like a dumbbell
schematically so one set of states
another set of states weak connections
you'll take very long so the conductance
measures the weakest connection between
any set of states and its complement and
the famous theorem of German Sinclair
says that the Markov chain converges in
time which is only dependent on Phi 1
over 5 squared so so it's clear that the
weakest connection can restrict you so
it's a necessary condition that there'll
be no weak condition will be connection
they prove that it's official there is
no weak connection weak subsets to
complement connection then you can
virtually
this informal term I'll say too formal
theorem so formally we have switched to
taking running averages so these P not
is a probability distribution at time 0
time 1 time t minus 1 I take the average
of those that's a running average that
gives you the probability of being in
state T the total and the expected
number of times being in safety over all
these things over each state in time T
and mixing time at mixing time you
visited everybody equally
everybody is one over N in a limit
that's true but you want to be close to
the limit you want all the probabilities
or fraction of time spent to be with an
epsilon of 1 over N and the theorem is
that there's a formal statement of them
you know the exact sector for symmetric
changes no oh no they need not be
regular should be this is for regular no
because as long as it's symmetric the
stationary probabilities are the same
for all vertices so maybe you're
thinking the daily condition was needed
to make this limiting probability is the
same okay but they are same as long as
it's symmetric and connected already I
mean if the graph is regular than ever
equally likely to weight every vertex
but so are you if it's symmetric so for
instance that so for instance even if
you had a part right with probability in
all half you're equally likely to be
neither so for instance I guess that's
regular I have to give you a better
example than that but it doesn't have to
be regular as long as it's symmetric
it's true
the stationery should be the degree or
the number of edges whatever you would
exist a big lead over the number of it
no see no star and back right and so
start if it's only one over n probably
because here is it maybe so start one
over n probability each way but I'm only
going to put one over in this way also
and the rest I'm going to do self so
it's not necessary to the do yet so the
self loose making it regularly well ok
so I still haven't come up with a non
regular somatic example but there are
lots of okay good yeah so yeah I was
there was a danger of ending too early
so so this works more generally for what
are called time reversible Markov chains
not just a symmetric change but I didn't
want to define
it's more gentle than cementery
so so I want to actually so some of you
are familiar with the proof some are not
but I want to give you a sort of a one
slide intuition about a sort of unusual
proof it's not the usual proof that you
see so the idea the proof is is of both
the fundamental theorem and the
convergent we went one step starting
from 80 so 80 where the fraction of time
you are so far spent right but you
observe that that's also probability
distribution live in advance to one over
all vertices so I'm going to do a
conceptual step one step starting from
that distribution it's not house by my
mind then the change happens that is you
you take that distribution starting hit
it with probability matrix P that's one
step and take the difference from what
you had and you see that all terms
cancel out because P naught times P is P
1 C 1 times P is P 2 and so on they all
cancel out except for the last two
person lost and that converges to zero
so the crucial argument is just based on
this that this this converges to serve
that's going to be the key argument okay
so some details in the rest of this
flight of them that when you see that
the numerator and denominator are equal
you should be happy if if the relative
weight of a state is is a steady-state
eighty is a fraction you spend so far so
VI is high means you spend too much time
and VI is low means you spent too little
time the net probability flow from I to
J in that one step in at one step if
there's a calculation don't worry about
that but the model is that probability
flows from heavy to light states in the
step okay sounds intuitively obvious but
just a little calculation so they need
your light witnesses and the probability
floor lemma which is central to the
proof is if you had two disjoint sets of
vertices with the first set each being
heavier than the second set then there's
a minimum certain amount of flow from
the first to the second so if I'm a
heavier than this then the four is a
much right that's the probabilities a
simple calculation now why is that good
we can also show that the net flow from
all heavy States to light States well
that's just a change and that's a minus
AP in l1 norm but we saw that that chain
goes to zero
so net flow from heavy to light states
goes to zero and this says if some
states are much heavier than others
there's a lot of flow you cannot have
that right so heavy vertices cannot be
much heavier than light ones if they
were the flow would be too heavy so this
can be completed to approve fits up the
reference in the book right so it's sort
of a more probabilistic proof now okay
I'm done tell us what kinds of settings
ER and CMC are being used
oh yeah good point yeah so a lot of
statistical mechanics things that I use
I mean Mike Mahoney did his PhD in
physical chemistry oh and the water
molecule and news
now we are also used in a geometric
setting to find volumes and of convex
sake not only volume for convex sets but
probability measures so suppose you have
suppose I have a Gaussian and I want to
know what the mass of this particular
set is right or yeah you get the
Gaussian is a failure property that
state you would like to compute for
regions which are very small failure
totally hopefully it's a reliable system
right you would like to compute the
probability master when you do them so
you can't integrate if this is a
complicated
it's a nice Markov chain Monte Carlo
again expected
any other questions
[Applause]